pittsburgh buffalo detroit the middle
class famous tour is coming your way
little mix of stand-up comedy play a
little ayg with the crowd it's going to
be a good time yeah guys get the homies
come out it's a good way to introduce
them to the show we're going to be in
buffalo on june 14th we're going to be
in pittsburgh on june 15th in detroit
june 16th get those tickets we'll see
you there yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they're earth to be classy yeah
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host age foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
at anthony's basement she's upstairs
she's organizing a new lemonade stand of
sorts okay but for catalytic converters
okay so if you're in the market and
you're looking for something cheap come
by the spot
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me unamused again this week i'm
striking out
he's my best pal in the whole wide world
and i love him give it up for kj kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always make sure your rate views fire
on writers
great review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube as you know
those numbers are true
cooking and then obviously the greatest
website of all time www.patreon.com
check it the [__] out ladies and
gentlemen it's a game changer over there
come see me in tuscany this summer and
i've been a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good you love them we
love them give it up for t-bone
mcbuttons toby mcmullen what's up dudes
what's up t-bone got a hot one man we
got a hot one we got the [__] kid in
here we got the coolest kid in school
the new kid coming in right
he's got a girlfriend up in canada but
we still love she's got she's got huge
tits
i've seen him in
everything he showed them to me
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly special guests back with
us again today extremely funny stand-up
comedian tours all over let me tell you
something this kid kills it on twitch on
tick-tock on youtube on instagram on
twitter and he's got a brand new special
his debut special right coming out june
5th on youtube called live at the lodge
room ladies and gentlemen give it up for
the pride of baltimore stavros
how we doing boys we're doing good well
i'm happy to be here i i would like for
the record to stay oh boy that i you
guys have had a lot of like big names
i'm i'm thrilled you're a big name i'm
thrilled to see you but you know we're
friends you know what i mean
i'd like for the record that i did this
podcast when i was sure it would fail
that i i
i'm returning now that it is a success
and i'm very happy for you but i
remember getting the email and being
like
all right ideals are funny guys
i'll do it for them it was early too
yeah it was early
pandemic it was in the middle of a
couple couple of months into the pot
yeah i was like this is good there one
last attempt and then
and then maybe if i'm at helium they can
feature for me
you know that's kind of how i approached
it and i'm very happy to see you guys
thriving and i love
[Laughter]
it true well i can say that's
the fact that you know the truth of
course means things should go on the
other side of it exactly
we've made it through the tunnel we're
on the other side that's patreon.com
keep hitting that patreon take one more
[Music]
i got a text a frantic text oh oh yeah
my internet's [__] let me
let me plug the router in i wasn't i
wasn't napping
you're sitting there with like the mics
and the cans on i'm like the zooms
recording i'm like have you heard from
nothing nothing
but i'm actually back the studio is
[__] sick and it looks awesome i
remember your camera turned on you were
brushing your teeth or something like
that going on boys good to see you i was
also losing my mind during the pandemic
so it actually was nice to talk to
someone and just do something that was
deep pandemic that was that was 400
grocery store orders that was [__]
crushing [__] uh breaking bad that
was that was knee-deep that was the
getting fat as hell oh
man we'll never see civilization again
part of the pandemic what a ride that
was it was a fun time man [__]
grocery store the pandemic was all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah congratulations on
the special thanks dude things have been
going incredibly well i'm trying wow
yeah before we get into the patreon
questions we want to do a little
follow-up here it's been a while
a couple of things let's do it
um i know you have a slight bone to pick
with me oh yes regarding
dug up some of my old tweets that's
right trying to get me cancer that's
what won
the old bay
yeah yeah yeah we've got a lot i feel
like that's that's me and fully's
relationship because he puts out a food
take and i'm like i'll execute yeah well
you're out of your mind i have a machete
i'm outside of your house strawberry
quick strawberry quick i'll kill you
the son of a [__] i think we also had a
pizza disagreement oh that's another one
i want to talk about this yeah yeah yeah
but i just wanted let's start i just
wanna
let's get it going i'm ready to [__]
[Laughter]
i want to clarify the old bay comment
all right because that's like sacred it
is that's like an angel dust where you
yes
yeah shrimp crabs okay but these bozos
up here in philly they put it on [__]
everything okay
crab fries are big where we i love them
you can't do you love them unimpeachable
crab fries are you out of your mind
really it's a [__] perfect it's it's
thank you what are you a little bit of
cheese on the side
a little yeah absolutely if you if you
can recreate like a cream of crab soup
this guy knows about it i'm on team
stuffy you know a little cream a little
cheese a little old bay get that look
cause listen we take a chowder soup we
want to liven up our fries
how many let's let the fries live are we
kidding we both shop at the same store
foley sure i've seen that shirt on the
dxl rack all right don't come at me
pretending you don't want different
variations of fries thank you it's not
like you're honest it's not a [__]
it's not a zero-sum game uh-huh there's
no need to bring dxl into this
they're good people stop hey i love you
don't hurt him over there listen i'm
back in unfortunately nine months in a
row of touring i had to dip my toes back
grab a sandwich i'm eating the dressing
room
tony
man but that's my point it's like give
me every type of fry yes okay i want it
out there i want it you don't want to
have it every day but you want the
option if you're there hey you know what
i've had the sweet potato fries i had
the regular cheese
give me the krabbies you like the old
bait chips too i would assume right or
yeah what are they heard that's a
delicacy or someone's got hers yeah
is that the silver bag
is the golden bag oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's all right they're good they're
very good they're very good i put them
on i put obey on pierogies i don't give
a [__] i'll do it on anything like
that's not a bad idea shrimp i think
they shine definitely it's shrimp shrimp
and there's nothing better than exactly
sucking off the [__] old day off
just sucking the crab leg
getting a little under the fingers yeah
the finger you get a cut it's painful
but that's how you know you're alive i
know unless you live on it yeah
where do you stand on uh montreal steak
seasoning montreal oh okay interesting
fan i this is
only on cereal
there's a reason this was a success
because
for [__] yeah all of our listeners
look like youtubers idiots like me yeah
this is these are the deep philosophical
questions i want to have i don't want to
talk you know it's a lot of snifter yeah
yeah yeah montreal seasoning is i would
say it's an is an entryway
it's a gateway into the larger seasoning
world
[Laughter]
i think that is a little bit it's tr it
is trash by the way i remember when
you're using salt and pepper
salt and pepper that salt and pepper
though it's like it can be elevated as
well
montreal your f your your mind is being
opened mm-hmm you're dipping your toe in
the water there and that's that's when
you're like if you grew up trash yeah
right and you want to escape
you throw a little montreal steak
seasoning on on some chicken
i remember the first time i had montreal
chicken the first time i had it it blew
my [__] hair back you think you're
like [__] you know it's like you know
it's like the way like if you if you
like it's kind of like reading a new
yorker article when you live in [__]
in like phil you know and like trashy
failure like wherever the [__] baltimore
it's uh some people don't mind expanding
it's a yeah it's doing mushrooms for the
first year it's like oh you
[__] know nothing about
montreal season i feel like i feel like
you're in turmerics you're [__]
around with ginger
see you know what i mean some fresh
ginger or something some [__] five
spices did you say turmeric i think it's
either one turmeric no it's turmeric no
way it's got to be turmeric t-bone help
me out it's not tumeric turmeric
turmeric a lot of people say tumeric
which is wrong that that might be the
most right one no that's we need a we
need a like an indian guy we need
somebody
truly it's what we need you know
what i'm saying is montreal seasoning
that's the gateway then you're having
differences it's right up the middle yes
from the orient you get a little fresher
reagan i was always an oregano guy being
greek obviously
but you know you're opening your mind up
to different the different things
silk road type stuff it is yes yeah yeah
yeah
i would say i'm i'm definitely past the
montreal steak seasoning point in my
life okay you know what i mean that's
over for me but i it was a beautiful
time
it's like your college girlfriend so i'm
glad we didn't get married but uh i wish
you nothing but me a lot of things yeah
yeah yeah yeah i learned a lot
was the first person to suck my day yeah
that's what i'm trying to say the toe
ring was hot but i gotta move on
uh i feel like what happened was is that
our dads or somebody went out to a
restaurant this is back in the day they
had it and then it filtered into the
home
see and then we got fed at one i
remember it was in the spring
my dad did some steaks on the grill
we're like what the [__] is on this it's
like montreal steak it was on
every single meal
sure sure that was it was like barbecue
sauce but barbie you saw something like
96 and then and this by the way all came
on the scene the fact that we're having
this discussion means we were all grew
up poor oh yeah because it's like this
there wasn't a lot of money like i'm
thinking about my roommate who like was
a kid who like you know grew up in the
dc suburbs his dad was like a computer
programmer like he was having [__]
ramen he was having real
real right
i'm still a little scared exactly
exactly he like he under you know had
that [__] going so for him he probably
that was never the case but yes dry rubs
montreal seasoning was the
was the first i mean again greek people
just like a little salt pepper oregano
montreal seasoning made me feel a little
[__] you know a little close a little
elevated right um but i don't i wouldn't
tie it to a restaurant i think it was
just
mccormick and schmidt yeah that just it
was there yeah it was there he's still
having it my mom like yeah still my mom
still throws it down
if they're firing up the grill the
[__] mo
montreal is coming out in fact i'm
getting a little i'm literally having a
flashback of making steaks on the
grill i put illegally on our balcony in
greek town i love that i had a summer of
grilling charcoal it was just it was a
gas grill okay this was a gas grill even
more dangerous but all right yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is what's something
that'll take out the whole block oh yeah
and i got one in or two completely
against code i have a guess
on my balcony i what i'm gonna [__]
i'm not gonna grill
in the summer with the [__]
you gotta know you gotta you got a
balcony you gotta go is it a balcony
where the other one is right above you
i'm on the i'm the highest oh good there
you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can't be smoking out the neighbors
in florida good point i never thought
about that but
has anybody said anything like any notes
nobody really says anything out there
the story is awesome everybody does it
everybody [__] keeps their mouth shut
the illegal balcony the illegal u-turn
and the [__] double parking out there
oh it's out of it is that absolutely
insane it's awesome whatever it keeps
their mouth shut and keeps it moving
they know yeah it's a it's a it's a it's
an incredibly diverse neighborhood a lot
of people from a lot of different places
and everyone knows just to [__] keep
yourself find your own business keep it
moving yeah and grilling unites all of
those cultures everybody likes a nice
perfect eastern european puerto rican
whatever the [__] it is you know
everybody's everybody's grilling did you
celebrate greek easter recently uh you
know actually this year my brother was
married on greek easter so it was nice
we had a double celebration
he got like he the meal was lamb chops
to make it real greek you know i was
like you know i was pretty adamant that
we got to have some [__] some lamb in
the middle yeah yeah if he hadn't made i
was like i swear to the wedding no dude
i literally was like i will hire a food
truck to bring lamb
yeah on the menu was it a big wedding
it was pretty small it was it wasn't
very big it would have been a flex but i
i surveyed the pla there would have been
no place to there was no parking it
would have been like yeah yeah yeah it
was like outside maryland it was like
yeah it was like uh it was a beautiful
venue but there was would not have been
an opportunity for a food truck a food
truck full of lamb we were going to get
to this eventually but since you brought
it up brother's wedding yes uh
like this what was uh
audible what was in the envelope what
was in the envelope
or what do you get a ton of money
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah a ton i don't
want to put my little brother on blast
definitely don't do that but of course i
want there is i just want him to have
the best wedding possible so if it was
like if there was something like this if
there was something that they like
didn't want us you know and he's yeah
he's like you know write it down he
wants you to write it down i don't even
remember like it was a rich guy thing to
do you don't talk about you write it
down i bet we've had bigger on the show
you've definitely had bigger for sure
but i'm just trying to think like in
terms of everything i paid for oh you
did that too i paid for the good guy
the envelope the envelope was a thousand
bucks
okay but there was definitely yeah yeah
there was some there was some
paperworthy
numbers
going into
going into the wrestling i mentioned the
lamb truck right yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right i got one for you just write
down i gave him a blender yeah yeah yeah
you got a new airfryer 48 dollars
that's a [__] that that is nice
that's [__] yeah i just paid for a
couple things look at that my brother
the other thing is with my brother
because again we are trash we can't we
don't we have no financial literacy
whatsoever he was like dude i got this
awesome credit card
i looked at that credit cards aren't
awesome and yeah and it was like first
gear no whatever and then it was like 88
i was like [__] if you don't pay
this off it is going to quadruple and i
just gave him
the balance and i was like and now i'll
just
every holiday until
uh ten thousand dollars worth i'm just
like that's he's just and that so i
would like to be clear i gave him
whatever i gave him on top of the debt
he's already incurred you know what i
mean is he younger he's younger
what a good man but yeah it's like he
was like yeah like
truly no one in my family understands
[__] sure uh that understands money
what including myself like i don't know
what the [__] we just had uh we did on
patreon my buddy's a financial advisor
he came in and blew our minds we are not
talking to this guy yeah yeah no dude a
financial advisor would [__] slap me
in the face oh dude fifty percent
they're like put fifty percent i'm like
fifty percent what do i gotta hang out a
little bit yeah yeah that's why i wanna
like party that's why i wanna just buy a
house because i have that dumb
that dumb villager brain where it's like
i don't wanna learn what stocks are no i
don't want to do any of this [__] i want
to buy a house and i'll just put all my
money into that and i want to [__]
maybe make a sick kitchen like you know
i've got those yeah i've got those
dreams of just a job stainless steel
[__] vikings everywhere the whole
[__] so you're not doing the bitcoin
the nfts
all that is [__]
you're a [__] dumb [__] if you have
any of that
and i want to be very clear about you
hear that ma yeah
i mean that's just another like america
is so [__] that they just have to
create new pyramid schemes to get people
asking us you're gonna do a garbage nft
i'm like we're comedians yeah i'm not
learning nfts also no they're [__]
stupid they don't you don't own it's
just like ownership you could argue that
no one really owns land right like i'll
hear that where it's like you can't
really we shouldn't have private
property i'll listen to that so now you
want to tell me that the idea of a
picture of floating somewhere yeah is
worth and then it's so funny because
it's like i think the money to be made
has been made maybe yeah some of the
like you know the technology will
probably stay around and stuff like that
maybe some of the blockchain [__] will
which i still don't understand but like
nfts it's over it's truly over well
somebody didn't see someone stole yeah
and he was like hey guys give it back
he just tweeted give it back what are
they taking the only thing they hacked
he's hackers and wasn't he in the movie
hackers exactly that's pretty [__]
interesting i don't think so who
seth green no not in hackers okay so he
went to get the picture you don't got
that he went to get the picture
make me look cool dude
he was literally looking at hackers
t-shirts to buy today so he went to get
the picture in the picture was gone see
this exact the fact that you can't
understand what's happening is an
indictment of how stupid this idea is
yes i think it's nerd [__] it stinks so
no i want a house
that's it yeah yeah you know i i agree
maybe you do on your i don't like that
commie talk
[Applause]
these [__] start making eight
grand on patreon all of a sudden all of
a sudden it's [__] pull yourself up
by your bootstraps
hey we got ted cruz coming in tomorrow
what are you talking
i've about brian kemp on the show next
week
now it's fun
goddamn stacy adams on my right
let's talk about butcher box put your
box put your box butcher box that's
right baby what do you like to grill
what's a guy like you do a little
chicken do a little fish that's
pedestrian sure i like a nice burger
maybe 100 grass-fed
maybe from some nice ground beef i like
a nice broth i like it all babies good
stuff you don't want to be going to the
grocery store dealing with that where
you're going to get top quality meats
you can get them delivered right to your
door with butcher box we're talking
about grass-fed gresh finish talking
about high-quality wild-caught salmon
seafood free range free right wild
caught some food good stuff and all new
subscribers the butcher box can receive
a free grilling bundle in their first
order spread like they've said a
thousand times they send it to us i've
re-upped on it i mean i'm coming out i i
got i got ground beef coming out my
gills
it's fantastic uh every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of
high-quality meat right to your home
free shipping in the continental u.s no
antibiotics no added hormones packed
fresh ship frozen for convenience so you
can save time in your next grocery store
trip delicious 100 grass-fed free-range
chicken pork raised crate free wild
caught seafood unbeatable value less
than six dollars per average on me where
are you gonna get that not in new york
tell you that much i got the crate stuff
at my house yeah thanks you'd be paying
99 dollars a [__] pound though break
free baby
so kick off grilling season right with
butcher box sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg to receive a free grilling bundle
with your first order you'll get two
you'll get two 10 ounce rib eyes five
pounds of chicken drumsticks and a pack
of burgers for free what's that number
that's crazy dude they're giving us
stuff they're giving a store away that's
butcherbox.comg to clean this deal do it
okay let's talk about under attack under
tact underwear let's talk about
underwear buddy i got it on right now
actually nice i swear to god i feel like
a badass oh it's real smooth too it
makes me feel sexy gotta get on that
under attack gang top quality stuff
feels good you don't feel like a bozo
walking around and best thing is battle
tested by special forces what i swear to
you holy [__] mine's got a holster on it
kitty for his little 22.
my little peashooter literally it's high
quality material anti-bacterial
anti-piling moisture wicking so you stay
fresh and dry all day best thing about
these i know a lot of dirt bags listen
to this show i've been wearing these bad
boys for about two three days if we're
being honest it's not anti-wiki
it's durable ultra light fade resistant
shrink resistant and the best part
almost 30 percent less than the
competition get under attack.com that's
get under tac g-e-t-u-n-e-r-t-a-c
dot com get 20 off site-wide with the
with the offer code garbage 20. once you
try these you're going to throw out your
old boxers old boxers make you feel like
you're in the 1920s these babies are
sleek moving i'm doing smash and grab
jobs with them i'm throwing flashbangs
at my wife there you go uh good job of
blackwater and if it's not enough
undertake donates a portion of its
profits to veteran-run organizations
that are actively fighting human
trafficking what are we doing these are
the good guys let's go get undertack.com
that's
getundertac.com offer code garbage 20 do
do it
i'd do the other one that would doubt
that the big one was the dominant first
pizza hut yeah we did that we did that a
while ago on the patreon absolutely and
you're
what are your thoughts well because we
were divided so this is where i see give
me the let me i want to weigh in on
where the fellas are here and i i think
i was able to turn him okay great right
i'm
saying
domino's as a whole
is better
because insane i think pizza hut had
glory days sure in the 90s they are
nowhere near that anyway so we're trying
we're discussing
peak
peak of the powers i don't think there's
any discussion no no no no no pizza hut
had it the buffet the [__] big red
diamond experiment everything yeah
the the pack talk about your first
glimpse of being an elevator yes
remember when you walked in there very
much the montreal seasoning of pizza
it's
absolutely of course space invaders
while the pie is cooking okay
it's
undebatable okay i like okay but we can
start there start there we can start we
have some common ground if you're on the
road you're in [__] you know
missouri yeah yeah right everything's
closed the only thing open is pizza and
dominoes what you're i'm still going
pizza hut really i really
she still can't find pizza hut that's a
problem okay the company if if the
argument hinges on accessibility it
hinges on you know uh the i mean true
just accessibility and i also think
pizza hut has a little issue here
because we are always going to measure
it by the greatness of its past sure
where domino's is a little johnny come
lately right it's like the roman empire
exactly exactly yeah it's like it's like
yeah exactly if you think if you're
comparing like italy now look [__]
nice though doing all right you know
what i mean now do they have do they
have they conquered half the world no
it's it's a little island of some
[__] greasy sexual harassers
but
you're not going to watch the lions
fight but there's some nice there's some
[__] nice beaches the food is good
and then domino's is i don't even know
what what's the country equivalent of
some shitty you know it's not shitty
it's pretty it's fine it's fine and
that's the
don't talk to me like i haven't had
dominoes recently i've had it but when
you get one where it comes out right and
it's hot and it's fresh and it's there
quick you order online not to talk to
anybody it's fine again fine
but i still i still say that the highest
even today
the high of a high pizza hut
is is better yeah chasing that 20 years
ago you're living in the past
we still have pan pizzas right we still
have a crispier little oil or crunchier
little [__] you know basically gloves
gone man
domino's doesn't pan pizza pretty well i
have i just have their their standard
dominoes but they they do the nice crust
with the parmesan butter or whatever and
here's the thing about that crust it is
an improvement fundamentally it's the
same crust fundamentally it's still the
same chew the same
mouthfeel right it's all the same [__]
whereas i contend that pizza hut does
have better crust and if you're if your
argument is look
domino's is like you know pizza hut is
the [__] you know the girl you were in
love with yeah the best you know she
would suck your dick you would go
cross-eyed like you're in the three
stooges she was the girl you dated with
rich parents exactly rich parents but
also but also she had empathy she wasn't
like them she had empathy you know i
mean she wasn't like republican foley
over here
didn't want to hear any comedy talk she
was giving 20s to homeless people you
know what i mean she was buying new
stuff didn't want you to feel bad hot
smoking hot but
she would disappear for a month you know
what i mean she would leave you hot and
cold and it's like if now i think i'm
the kind of guy i'd rather chase that
love affair than
a seven and a half that's always there
for you and that's what domino's is you
know
you can't get it we can't get it here
right you can't get a domino's in a
store era you can't get a pizza in the
store you're correct pizza hut i don't
even know where they dude there's
nowhere put sound but that's not even
there when's the last time you had
passed
let's start there that's it that's an
interesting question but to be fair i
don't have dominoes that much either
it's true i i have i haven't had those
in the last 365 days
i don't know actually truly i don't know
maybe not is the answer because i when i
get pizza i get like it i have my spots
in the story of their local champions
it's more of like we i mean we travel a
lot obviously i like uh i mean my
well there's that don't believe i
haven't done baluchi's yet just opened
um i like crave they got good wings too
uh for just dude the quickest a pizza
has ever gotten to me um is uh
retro you know retro on broadway
i swear it's on my block yeah i swear to
god
the quickest appeal it's i have put it's
not even a phone call i put it on
seamless it has come to my house nine
minutes later i love that and it's it's
fully like seven minutes away sure like
i don't understand they're [__]
pretty
truly like it's gotten there so fast
where i'm like like i didn't even i
thought it was my friend or something i
had no idea like i was [__] i just
hit the door and the guys bang i'm like
what the [__] house in here ready
already
they beat their seamless like uh uh
estimation by 20 minutes routinely
so
and it's not the highest quality pizza
but it gets the job done right better
than
yeah dominoes you're not exactly you're
it's dominoes
not getting dominoes in new york we're
obviously on the road a lot you get done
the shows later you're in a smaller town
a lot of times the only game in town is
now look i'll be honest here i have not
been to a pizza hut in a while it's very
possible that i'm still living in these
i think you're living in the glory days
man and i would love now now i feel like
i have to go to a pizza
i feel like i need i should have
prepared you want to find one
i hope you're in [__] omaha
there's none there's no like sit down by
pizza hut that's another thing they cut
all those out okay and that's an issue
but the wing street it's that and the
wink get the [__] you're right here with
the waste stream but i hate that i hate
that hybrid [__] that's an issue across
uh fast food corporations yeah
corporations they have tried to make
these [__] disgusting baked wings
happen and that's everybody in the
consumer's face
a wing needs to be fried put a [__]
fryer in there or suck three minutes
yeah what are we doing here
out of control domino's wings are you
know the wing is a wash they're all dog
shoes yeah i'm not judging it on the
[__] pasta you're a gentleman listen
to that yeah yeah no cheesy crust
you know what you know what i'll say the
cheese you know where they have pizza
huts
that is actually a really reliable thing
is on the [__] 95 rest stops oh yeah
i don't mind that i don't mind that's
that's honestly probably my last that's
what you're you're down to [__]
truckers are getting blown that's where
you
i'm [__] commute i'm on the jersey
turnpike i'm paying eighty dollars in
tolls to have a personal pizza
but i will say that is their strength
i'll i'll give them that that chewiness
that's that's their yeah like baseball
games and [__] so like and to me it's
just you know
but again i'm more of a romantic like i
said i like this i'm a home run hitter
not a great but not a great batting
average right i like it i don't want i
respect i respect you guys can dink and
dunk get your little singles with your
with your [__] dominoes i'm [__]
i i miss a lot but man when it connects
does it connect nice and that goes well
that will never happen i promise
i'll give you that as a child there was
something
the butteriness
the texture the oily the little bit of
crispy the garlic that was kind of on
the crust yep
man it was just
absolutely and i will even say their big
gimmick
stuffed stuffed crush not eve one of
their not their best pizza no regular
pizza is better yeah yeah of course i
even loved their thin crossback
[__] all right salad bar goddamn yeah
like a [__] gentleman i there was one
in dundalk maryland i wonder if it's
still open and if it is i'm going to go
the next time i'm in baltimore i'm going
to go back i was going to buy it i am
going i might dude
i technically don't talk about it
[Applause]
i bought that in a blockbuster i think
it would be all right
the one in my hometown that's i'm a
little sour the one in my hometown
mine's at dry cleaners yeah yeah mine
turned into a bank
it's tough to see those but a kid was
[__] in the [__] in the tomato sauce
or something
and then serving it and he got arrested
for like endangering uh senior citizens
that's awesome because he got delivered
to a uh retirement that's hysterical
yeah he was like 13 or whatever wow
did he ever did he ever speak to his
motivations behind probably he was just
a teenager trying to be cool or whatever
yeah pretty sure he's nothing says for
sure like [__] like sitting in some
putting her ass cheeks on a big can of
pasta sauce he shot himself as they
closed in on him
our favorite flavor of gatorade
[Music]
interesting
it's i would say it's between the
classic yellow and the classic blue
great uh and the frost i'd have to i
think push comes to shove gun to my head
i'm going frost okay and having said
that i like the [__] around i like to
you like the white one the wild that
one's all right big now a lot that's a
lot of people's favorite right now you
know what i'm you know what i'm kids on
tech talk today you know what i've
dipped my little nuts into recently i
was
i've i've
sauced yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was
between yeah that guy was [__]
between my legs
um
i tried body armor
uh peach like mango and i'll say this
i've tried the nah the diet and the full
the diet's better okay so i'm a big bot
i don't i can't that's not an energy
drink though right it's a gator it's a
gatorade competitor they got like
hardened they have a couple of baseball
players i don't know you know they've
they've tried to like really get into
the space that's exactly the market
share
don't they drink that a bar stool don't
they have that
body armor
yeah so
i will say that flavor and i can't i
just discard like i i had it for the
first time i was in dc to like last
weekend or two weekends ago and there
was hilariously there was a standalone
wawa in the middle of downtown dc right
across the street from my hotel it was
nice no gas station no gas station old
school and i gotta say it was [__]
sick
because it was like yeah it was like
across the street from my hotel i you
know there's like little there's like
little benches around there me and my
[__] buddy eldest shout out to eldest
uh who was with me we were just getting
wawa and we were [__] getting high
smoking a joint drinking some body armor
and
whatever getting hyped for a game that's
never gonna happen yeah yeah yeah i was
using more as recovery
let me get a pedialyte in the meatball
sub yeah two hours of stand up comedy
and then the damage i was doing with
what i ordered uh at wawa but there's
something about that peach mango okay i
have to do it i like it i have to get in
the lab it's very reminiscent of a
specific flavor
from childhood that i can't put my food
i completely agree with you we were just
talking about these ice things they're
called ice they're called spark
sparkling
ice bottles it's like zero calories and
there's they're flavored it's like
sparkling water type thing they have an
orange mango
thing i'm like i don't know i have one
yes going on i go i don't know what it
is it's a little sunny dish
it's a little something and it must
it must be some kind of chemical exactly
that was in a maybe a capri sun
cooler or something like something like
that but not quite not as tart yes as
the ecto cooler a little lighter
yes yeah yeah peach mango
were you guys so be people back in when
you're just kids no that wasn't that
that was [__] lollapalooza
i was
[Laughter]
every once in a while and it just i
would do it but as a poser yeah
[Applause]
it was in my heart it felt weird i would
get them just to be cool just just to
pretend i'm not these guys
but ultimately something was off i will
admit it never never i love how you're
trying to distance yourself
i've always been crazy
exactly we just debated domino's version
seriously for 20 minutes i'm not like
these losers no exactly that's always
been that's always been how i've seen
myself i'm like i'm better than everyone
i grew up with like we had a very
similar you know shitty uh yeah middle
class middle class
what's the [__]
i'm sorry this is dirtbags suburban
working class scumbags no no no this is
republican regional
sorry my third podcast of the day yeah
what about uh
would you were you guys around same
thing that was that was opie was all
right we couldn't touch it remind me
henry it was very
but they were good and here's one that
you probably said deep deep deep i'm
ready clearly canadian you know what i'm
talking about they were in like perrier
bottles they looked like sparkling water
but they were actually flavored they had
flavors yeah they had sugar in it they
were they were yeah they would not do
the raspberry one of those would knock
your socks off i was a big
i was a big um
arizona iced tea of course
of course that was my goal
of course
i still wasn't a huge snapple guy i mean
my dad was big on snapple from like
price club and [__] sam's club and
that kind of [__] we were lava iced tea
though growing up wawa iced tea was that
was in the fridge
gallon yeah yeah we were
truly the drinks were even shittier than
what we're talking about remember that
[__] tampico
that [__] like by the gallon like i
don't truly like radioactive i don't
know that time i'm gonna start pissing
myself from you no true that's why the
laundry detergent no no exactly that was
nowhere near a cooler no that was true
exactly oh that stuff yes yes yes yes
yes that's like fake orange listen what
can i say here's the thing you're trying
to hear the [__] happening here's the
difference i grew up with less money
more class this is poverty you know what
i mean this is my mother
what are you talking about yeah
[Laughter]
my mom took us to museums yeah your mom
was getting you that yeah that's that is
literally that was he was trying to play
up she was like i honestly did not
understand how poor we were
and it was like looking at this i'm like
that went in my body it was dude it was
my favorite me and my brothers were like
tampico
were [__] addicted to the sugars yeah
yeah yeah i think my mom tried to wean
us off and we would we were like [__]
shake shake yeah yeah but yes that is
that is definitely like that's truly
yeah i need to make 20 stretch
drink you know what i mean and it was
like we had and we did for a while we
did [__] uh juice from concentrate
until we got too snooty for that like
that's all that was orange when i was
like yeah yeah yeah i used to get in one
of those
eat it like a popsicle
powder mom would freak out then she
would have to make
the [__] then she'd have to make it
with half of it my brother's like what
the [__] that sucks
thank your brother he ate it all
[__] screaming at me
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yikes kevin's talking about tightening
tight and tight and tight in this day
and age if you need if you don't know
how to do something what do you do do
you try to figure it out yourself or you
hire an expert to do it
you hire an expert to do it why would it
be different when it comes to investing
listen this crypto thing is real
okay a lot of stuff's real going on out
there and you gotta get on titan they
can help you out they got experts to
handle your financials yeah uh as
everyday investors the cards are stacked
against us if you're the little guy the
day trader you're trying to put i got
500 here i got 100 that you don't know
what you're doing yeah you know what i'm
not picking lottery numbers anymore yes
but we've been getting we've been given
access to the marketplace of stocks but
we're competing against institutional
investors with unlimited resources
you've got teams of guys going over
charts and graphs meanwhile you're
picking your belly button men's men with
jobs i know uh but when you're wealthy
you have access to these teams of
experts of different types of portfolios
investment vehicles and much more
growing your long-term wealth isn't
something you should just do yourself
you can sit back
you shouldn't just sit back and shoot
for average returns with titan you have
personal investment team that researches
and invests for you and then can they
aim to outperform the market while
giving you a courtside seat to become a
smarter investor along the way to get
with titan you get access to strategy
similar to those with the one similar
similar to those in the one percent
without having to be ultra wealthy or
pay hefty fees
all it takes is a hundred bucks to get
started you deposit your money
uh selected with the portfolios you want
to invest in and that's easy peasy me
and you both got set up not too long ago
they put a couple of free bucks in our
account where i'm playing chess over
here what's that give me two of those
one of them two shabby um check out
titan if you want to aim to become a
smarter uh wealthier investor than
you've ever been so head to titan.com
garbage you get 50 when you invest with
titan you must go to the url
um or you will not get the 50 and they
will not know we sent you that's 50 when
you go to titan.com garbage and invest
with titan
free 50 bucks give it a shot yes this is
a sponsored podcast ad i'm a client of
titan and invest
in multiple
things in my portfolio check it out not
back to the show back to the show any
clocks in your house that are wrong
right now
in a microwave that's a good question my
oven may be wrong i haven't i haven't
checked okay i've been literally i did
just spring forward too not too long ago
my car's wrong yeah yeah yeah car was a
big one i haven't been to my car since
that so probably but yeah oven
could be wrong but see my roommate is uh
one of my best friends he's like my best
friend from college and uh we kind of
live like a like a gay couple with like
two incomes you know
and he uh he is kind of he's like a
little
like
anal about things like that so he
probably he probably takes care probably
checked it but he's also been gone so
i'll text you i'll go home i'll text you
like does he keep the house tight he
does he hits the reason like like i'm
the problem in the house for sure like i
could have picked up yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude if i show like
i if he he's like in portland right now
if he cut his trip earlier if he showed
up today i would be mortified dude
my luggage is just on the couch like i
got back
monday i got back monday it's what is
today thursday yeah my i haven't like my
just luggage just kind of zipped that
because i had no i i did laundry before
i left so i was like oh instead of
putting my clothes back i've just been
taking it out yeah
yeah i'm in my own home living out of a
suitcase i haven't unpacked since
chicago yeah yeah yeah yeah
i have just a bat like a
hefty bag like a garbage industrial bag
of every night's seamless order that
just goes
right in there and yeah put it back on
your bra
that's just like you know kebabs sushi
whatever the [__] whatever i know you're
a piece of [__] when you're opening that
bag and you intend to keep it like you
don't rip it yeah yeah yeah you can use
it later to make the cleanup easier
because you know you're a piece of [__]
yeah and i just don't clean up till the
next day oh yeah it's like you know i
just like get
i just eat that that's my [__]
heroine and i just eat way too much and
then i pass the [__] i take a couple of
melatonin so i'm trying to get off the
weed right now and i just pass the [__]
out wake up the next day groggy is a
[__] and just like all this dried like
sauce and rice
chip it off the table and [__] like that
so you saw us everywhere it's brutal no
my apartment sucks right now how's the
uh how's the credit score these days
very good credit very good always had i
always did have pretty good credit yeah
yeah yeah because i uh i didn't have
any student debt okay and my father was
so in debt that it scared me sure so i
just never had any until
until i bought that house in greek town
uh-huh i and i guess my car loan okay i
had no those were the only two that was
the only time i was ever in debt so you
own your car own my car what are you
rolling around then
2012 corolla okay you know still making
payments on it no no i was going to say
what the [__] that's the whole reason i
you think i just
got a 90 year old two years left on this
bad boy
yeah my monthly payment is eight dollars
i'll be passing it off to my son
he can um what what kind of air
freshener are you kicking around with in
that coral oh no freshener just wrong
dog yeah yeah yeah yeah stop me baby
what's that car like is it a tough scene
in there you know it's how many water
bottles on the ground solely because
i've basically stopped driving i've been
on the road so much
my car is my car i've parked under a
tree for three weeks it looks like i
just pulled it out of a swamp yeah yeah
it looks like it was underwater i'm
actually thinking about giving it to my
mom because i just don't
uh i'm a fresher man
yeah freschetta is bad
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think that's square yeah yeah yeah no
it's not i just chopped up a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was that there was a moment in my
life in our lives where i was like where
we upgraded to fresher because that my
mom did it i think i think um
sam's club or costco whichever one
started carrying those
and that was a big moment i was like
whoa we're doing all right oh you want
you eat digiorno dude digiorno we were a
tombstone house cool and we had the
jordan you'd like to join all right
freschetta over digiorno all day sure
but that's self-rising crosstalk nothing
yeah
nice glass of milk
we got you can't
[Music]
that makes me so [__] mad and what
makes it worse is that there's like a
sizeable part of the population
50-50
these people are walking around and we
don't know it it's like horrible there
might be people i love you know it
creates a consistency in your mouth
where it feels like you're eating caulk
or something it's not good stinks dude
it really is horrendous i like you
peeing in the shower i assume right of
course brush your teeth in there i do
not really i have a you know
expensive toothbrush
here's here's trash is it electric it's
electric but i started brushing my teeth
every day when i turned 30.
i think you're going to talk about trash
that was one of those like i was like
overworked mothers
just like you know there's one thing you
just didn't do it sure she was like uh
brush your teeth she's so tired that she
just never ever thing and it was
literally i wasn't even losing my tooth
that did it for for whatever reason it
was just like
one day i woke up i was like i should
brush my teeth did you lose your tooth
because of decay no it was like it was
something random that's the thing it's
like it wasn't that it was just yeah you
know so it was like an old injury
apparently that just gets worse over
time right and you don't like it should
have it if i don't even know what it was
but it just kind of started getting
weaker and then the final straw was
cracking it on a chicken wing but not
brushing my teeth had nothing to do with
that and i think are you flossing
i've got flossers the little guys okay
do you know the brand check out glide i
think it's i think i'm glad the green
ones yeah they're orgasmic when they go
in yeah they go in real [__] smooth
yeah what about uh in the in the bedroom
there do you sleep with your socks on
no what do you sleep it's crazy i'm a
boxers guy just boxers don't sometimes
i'll go fully nude sometimes fresh out
the shower cleansing sheets feels great
i'm rubbing my little my little fresh
nuts all over that are those sheets
clean
i i at most i'll go two weeks without
how do you do the laundry do you drop it
off a drop off yeah
i'm
stunned and in prep two weeks two weeks
tops
sometimes i'll switch them out i would
go
18 months if i didn't have a wife
yeah i would i don't think i would ever
it's bad here's here's clat here's
here's a new money class the reason it's
two weeks is because we get a [__]
cleaning lady and she does them every
two weeks she does them yeah yeah i i
will if i want to i'll do them you know
once if there's been a particular if
there's been a couple [__]
you know it's like maybe one day i'll
enjoy a little hint of [__] sheets but
like after that you gotta change a
couple of squares
wait hold on the cleaning lady's doing
the laundry what do you have a washer
and dryer in the building i no no i set
out to clean sheets and she'll change
she changes them that's
wow
that's like rich guy [__] yeah that's
what i picture like it's awesome yeah
exactly so does every pillow in your
bedroom have a pillow case it does wow i
am stunned by it it does it comes i
picked it up
i pictured you on a single mattress no
sheets on the floor
that's me seven years ago you know six
years ago for sure is your bed in the
corner
absolutely okay a couple [__] couple
floating shelves on either side tv in
the room tv in the room but i got a this
is a tv called the frame i got that
there we go yeah yeah which which color
frame did you go away we just still have
the we didn't actually put the phrase
see that's you know well i see i don't
yeah the frame is nice because no one
knows it really is i first thought it
came with it and then it came and then
we were me and my wife were looking i'm
not sure and then it looks
from what i've seen it i haven't seen it
in person but you're you're telling me
in person it makes a huge difference
where people are like
they're cool it doesn't look like a tv
with the frame on they're just like what
is it they'll be like is it some kind of
like art what the [__] is it and then
you turn the tv on it's like kind of
sick you know that's how you get the
girl squirt totally yeah yeah i like it
it's the lg frame you see that painting
over the airplane yeah yeah yeah what's
the news well it is funny because they
pitch it as like hey you can
no i've never put a screensaver up you
have one that pops like i press a i
don't know why i'll ramble in denmark
yeah yeah yeah yeah try to get laid over
here buddy i just i keep it off and it
just looks kind of nice cool with the
frame on
so yeah tv though you gotta have it as
far as wings go
now we're finally getting into it the
drumstick or the flat
you know i was a drumstick guy and i've
become a flat guy are you doing the new
thing that the kids are doing with the
flats now are you crazy smoosh it down
i've i just i have always done that but
in my own mouth i have always just
you know i've learned the ways you know
the way hot girls would tie a cherry
stem the fat guy equivalent is putting a
drumette in your mouth check out tom and
jerry
exactly exactly
you see what fish was yeah the whole the
whole boat that just bones come out
all right
i am a drummer you know i am a flats guy
i'll have them both obviously come on
where are we talking about here
first honest thing the man said
guy's not north korean what are we doing
here
what's going on and i have to shout out
the american comedy have you guys done
san diego that we did la jolla
la jolla well
they had insanely good wings really i
will say and i'm a wing connoisseur the
seller has probably the best wings i've
had in new york really good wings
they're so good wild but there was
something about the [__] american
comedy company
fry was just right yeah just the right
kind of crunch love a nice crunch yeah
soggy wings people can [__] wings up so
easily easily most people do i would
most people do yeah i think you're right
are you rancher blue cheese the wings
i will say so ranch a high quality ranch
is my favorite qr but the problem is
those are hard to come by hard to come
in
that's one of the secrets of the seller
they're they're right whatever that is
right well i'm saying blue cheese is the
dominoes of sauces okay where it's like
consistent across the board you know
what you're getting ranch is kind of
pizza hut and i will say
in this instance i go you know i hold
out for the ranch but i'll happily
settle for the blue okay okay and if i
if i'm real and look we got we got sauce
money
i'll get them both
i know this isn't 2000 or 75 2015.
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm getting
appetizers i'm getting sauces baby what
do you dip your chicken tenders in
i i'll get real buck wild with that
whatever they got i'm making sauce i
mean i'd like to have a honey mustard
just as the you know emergency qb like
it's just there i know it's there but
if you got an interesting sauce i'll dip
my tender of course
let me [__] around and see what you got
that's the [__] kind of guy i am
i got number time and money to burn baby
give me a habanero mayo i'm putting my
[__] in there give me some kind of
cilantro based [__] chimichurri i'll
[__] put that in there he said that
like he was splitting the atom
dude i don't know what you're running
for but i'm voting yeah
oh yeah i'm team stavy this kid's uh his
kids are right he's got a strong
backbone i like to kyle like the cut of
his jib i'll tell you that right now
i got one uh because the baltimore
uh philly accent are very similar yours
is like a little slower uh you know a
little more drawl on it sure how do you
pronounce
the product created by crayola
oh oh oh crayon you say crayon well i
don't know
you just
here's the thing i don't have i don't i
can do the accent yeah but i don't you
know my influences were greek people
right so i talk i don't really have like
a baltimore accent uh-huh but it's like
if i was doing the the baltimore guy he
would be like
let me think about that crank yeah he
would it would be like
what do you guys say crown price i say
crown he says i said crayon crane crayon
crane
stop right there's like six people that
said crayola crayon
yes when you threw when you threw
crayola on there you hear your outfit
you really [__] yeah the the
the the [__] juxtaposition of crayola
and it's crazy crayon it's a crayon yeah
i don't know that sounds like an alien
over crayon crayons no yeah it's not
cram i say crown which is wrong right if
you say crayon i say crayon that's yeah
that's good the the baltimore accent is
only like
it comes in every once in a while but
you know i'm mostly immune most of the
people that i was taught that was who i
was talking to like greek down is a very
like insular little can you speak greek
you can yeah i'm fluent can you write it
i can i my spelling's not great in greek
and i can read it but i read it like a
[__] dumb ass like i probably read
like as like a stupid sixth grader okay
you know pretty like fully but i can
read i can talk um
i can speak yeah i can speak it pretty
good nice that's pretty impressive
that's classy thanks man has anybody in
your family anybody you know at all ever
ever claimed that they saw ufo
or bigfoot you know no nobody i'm trying
to think i mean
my cousin has started getting my greek
cousin actually started getting a little
into like
it's funny how like like q anon [__] is
like filtering into the rest of the
world sure because it's like it's not he
doesn't care that much but it's like
this is a guy who was like very liberal
very like left growing he's hitting
greece in greece yeah and then he just
like went he got
ver weirdly anti he became an
anti-vaxxer weirdly but there's never
been like and he had he said something
hilarious where he was like he was like
he was like kind of a trump guy but
doesn't really care obviously it was
like let me ask you this if trump is
racist then how come martin luther king
jr's son voted for him and i was like
i don't think i don't think he did where
are you
i'm pretty sure he didn't he was like
really i was like yeah i don't think so
he's like oh like he just he hadn't even
like
thought about
standing up to any scrutiny he thought i
was gonna have to be like well
sure that's a good point but
um but yeah so no i can't think of it it
would be him though probably
he's anybody
if anybody sees one in the future he's a
funny weird guy and he's i love that he
is definitely a [__] he's a [__]
piece of trash for sure his whole
he spent i mean he kind of got [__]
because he grew up in greece
he's the he's the direct generation that
got [__] by the financial crisis in
greece where it's like
everyone his age just didn't have a job
so he spent his like 20s working yeah
like he would work you know tourism was
the one industry that was popping off in
greece so he would go to an island
theoretically to work for the summer but
he would just like he didn't have a room
he would sleep in a tent geez and he
would just like [__] as many tourists as
possible i heard that's big yeah in in
in greece totally to get it to get a
good night's sleep yeah yeah you had to
get that nut off um and he just spent
his like and he was like oh yeah i'm
going there to work and then one summer
i went there and it like kind of
coincided with we were both going back i
was going back to athens the same time
he was going back and i was like oh
you're taking like this you know oh
there's a perfect boat that gets us
there really quickly he's like he's like
yeah that one's like 40 euros more i'm
gonna have to take the
overnight boat to save like literally 40
euros yeah he did not have the money to
get him to get a
normal manner to get to get home it was
like a cargo hole he had the it was like
a mega he got the mega bus
the mega boat the mega boat
he took the mega boat for sure it's got
luggage on his seat but it would be him
for sure and i'm you know i'm interested
to see like literally within
an hour of being in greece the last time
i was there he was showing me like
videos of of like
the this couple [__] at a at a
metallica concert it was like he was
just shorting he rules no he's the best
but he's just like he was like an old
metal head and like he was like dude
this is pretty sick it's just some girl
just getting railed out and maybe it was
in the metallica it was just some metal
show but it was like some guy's just
[__] uh and like someone's just like
yeah some [__] [__] is getting just
destroyed and he's like pretty cool he's
not horny yeah it's nice
she just wants me to see something
awesome yeah
like have you seen this
just imagine a guy with two beers
standing behind him like yeah it's my
girlfriend yeah yeah yeah i like to try
to class it up and say it was a
metallica show yeah yeah
he's that he's seen a lot of metal [__]
like he's he's awesome he one time he
went to see he loves ozzy osbourne loves
black sabbath and he went to see ozzy
osbourne in london and ozzie threw his
bucket of waters right not a who gives
it's like literally just a [__]
bucket
he went to secure it like he went to
just take it with him through security
in london they're like
oh on an airplane yeah to go back to
greece and they're like you can't can't
bring a metal weird metal bucket and it
wouldn't fit in his luggage he didn't
want to like fold or break it and he
somehow he was like i'm not he's like
i'm taking the bucket and he got it and
he's somehow like the power of love for
a bucket of
his fandom yeah yeah yeah howard pushed
him through this post 911
you know yeah
he rocks for she was in the 80s yeah
yeah yeah um we're going to do a couple
from patreon let's do it and then we
gotta we gotta wrap her up let's [__]
do it um
this one's from eddie have you ever been
so high you put your turn signal on for
a normal bend in the road
like you've been so you you're just
going i like that 100 yeah i feel like i
have i will say eddie i was i was so
high on my flight back from san diego
that i'm still not sure where my laptop
is this was four days ago
and i remember in the [__] seat
well i remember putting it in my
backpack i have a memory of putting in
my backpack and i was i took so many
edibles i was high the whole day and i
pretty sure i used it in my apartment
and then i went back to the place i have
a memory of it being and it's just not
there because i was just on like i mean
yeah on mars
probably like a hundred twenty
milligrams jesus jesus and yeah bobby
baby gets after it yeah yeah
i had a rough weekend i needed to sleep
it off and
so i truly just don't know
like i'm gonna go check my that's part
of the reason i need to clean my
apartment not just because of fear of my
roommate but like do i have to call
delta i mean it's been probably yeah
it's probably just gone now who gives a
[__] they probably they tend to keep
them i think okay maybe
but yes i'm pretty sure i've done that
but no
to answer our man eddie's question here
i know nothing in particular comes to
mind okay and speaking of flying do you
fly business or first class
comfort or what are you doing you only
fly delta i only fly delta and it just
depends you know like price-wise yeah i
let my nuts hang a little bit in san
diego this was a first-class flight back
um and if i'm go if i'm doing something
for work where i have to be there and
sometimes i'm like well you gotta treat
yourself i'll do it yeah especially if
it's like a tight turn around and i just
wanna sleep literally like i'll do that
but you know i try not to i still have
that
i'm going to be poor of course
so like wherever i can i just like get a
[__] like i'll go ex my big move is
exit row regular you know okay because
it's like they're pretty roomy sure
where are you at you an aisle or window
guys
exit row exit row can i ask you this bit
of a personal question please are you a
seat belt extender guy or no you know
that's it's really unfortunately it is a
case-by-case basis now and i used to be
a full no okay and that was one of the
most full yes
i guessed i was gonna get i didn't want
to say it
i was leaning yes
it's tough that's a tough one the reason
i ask is i got removed
from the exit row because you're not
physically capable they don't think
you're physically
fat phobia i got i got rid of yeah you
guys are all racist yeah yeah yeah i got
removed from the exit row that's a tough
one with my girlfriend in tow
the girl involved they wouldn't let her
stay but they were she's like oh honey
well they go they go we sit in the exit
row and then the lady walks around like
hey can i grab a seat belt extender they
get the seatbelt extended they come back
and she's like
unfortunately i can't have you sit here
you're too fast would anybody switch
yeah yeah yeah my girlfriend's like i'm
gonna stay here
i'm gonna i'm gonna take the middle seat
i'm fine but i'm eating your cheez-its
then
[__]
[Laughter]
you pay for your own
a basket a basketball team got on one of
our flights and sat next to me on the
aisle and foley was on the window and i
saw him talking [__] about foley in his
group text
you didn't tell me
that piece of [__] oh that's [__]
hilarious no that's a real tough one and
that's why it's like that's also why
like i had to fly southwest recently and
that's brutal because it's like
i need to be above this like i'm i'm on
a plane i don't need that bus energy of
sure someone i just use the fly spirit
we just i'm like it's always clearly the
cheapest but i'm like i just you can't
do that you can't do that you should
lose money
yeah i need to know where my seat is
because i hate that as a fat man i know
you know this where people just like are
scanning and just
frantically trying to do the math and
when they've done it and they're like
they cannot avoid sitting next to you
they're just like
i'm just like
yeah
treat him like a body pillow treat toby
so but then if there is an open seat
available toby then moves you know what
i mean like if there is of course of
course we try to protect the big man at
all you would think
if anybody from the airline industry is
out there get rid of that bar
at the doors yeah that one doesn't go up
if that went up you changed you mean the
arm rest yes because the one in the
aisle goes up and then once we take off
i pop that over and i'm [__] ash dude
i didn't realize sometimes i didn't know
he was chilling till the [__]
cocktail car i turned around i got up to
go to the bathroom like when they took
when like you know we were allowed to
move and i turn around and he's behind
dude he was in like the whole like
you could
dude i left it was like the my favorite
favorite visual moment i've ever had
i'm like oh there's oh
dude
[Laughter]
oh that's when your knee gets just
[__] brutalized by the cart you're
like and i feel like fat people are the
only ones when they come up with the
snacks she just hands me all three
doesn't even ask never says yeah and i'm
like handsome to me get these nuts out
of my face [__] and give me two
chocolate kind bars
those things are all right
those mini cook bars ain't nothing i
wouldn't eat them
peanut butter minnie cliffy those are
great those are great
keep the biscov's coming mm-hmm i don't
mind the biscoff those are the diet
cokes all right those are blowing up up
in here though they get they get up in
your uh they get all up in my teeth
never had the biscoff butter
the cookie butter no i heard it's good
though
you want to get in there you want to get
in there all right i'll give it a whirl
yeah
that was for foley
are you we were connecting
are you going to go see top gun 100
thank you a thousand percent if you had
to choose between an ice cream cone
regular
sugar
pretzel waffle
wow what are you doing what's stopping
waffle okay i like a nice waffle
gentleman yeah yeah yeah i like that
i'll take that again oh right i think
you got a yeah that's like the montreal
seasoning it's like you gotta yeah
you're elevated
sometimes you do just one guys
of course yeah oh mr softy you get you
get a regular coat yeah yeah of course
[__] [__] can't get a waffle at mr
software we were talking about bad
snacks when we were kids we were talking
about croutons last week i i remember
just eat croutons 100 yeah i remember
yeah absolutely i remember also just
bacon bits oh yeah yeah 100 nothing like
being like a piece of [__] being eight
and being at a all-you-can-eat buffet
with a salad bar coming back with one
piece of lettuce that is basically
serving be acting as a second plate yeah
and just [__] it up with croutons
bacon bits and ranch and just making a
little like a pre-diabetic soup
more of a challenge a little shredded
cheddar over there yeah yeah yeah nice
little
gazpacho
but i used to just eat uh ice cream
cones by
themselves jesus real sad
it's honestly rare that somebody can say
something that even i'm like god damn
like someone can out fat child me and
you know you got me there's anybody that
can do it you got me there with just
[__]
um
let's do two more from the patreon we
can wrap her up
um it's from matt have you ever had to
go ask have you ever had to ask a shoe
store employee to borrow a sock to try
on a shoe
that's a bad one or ask for the shoe
horn uh not the shoehorn but i have well
i've never asked but they have these
they have those little [__] i like
them yeah yeah they make me feel like a
ballet dancer yeah yeah feels like
you're wearing pantyhose exactly yeah
yeah it just helps me up a little bit
exactly we get that we get to uh uh uh
experiment with our gender identity in a
safe space with those yes it's like oh
it's like you're trying on shoes
i'm in foot locker oh back again yeah i
just wanted to try some stuff i love
your blouse
i remember one time i went my parents
took me out to get new shoes and like i
took my shoes off and there was just
like they were mostly holes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah [__] pc we look
like
like proper that's like depression
like trailer [__] yeah yeah yeah that
was the thing about being being like
that when we were kids there was always
such an emphasis on
not letting anybody know you're
everybody knew it yeah but certain
things yeah if you get dirty socks
what's wrong with you
barry yeah screaming
will you are you a water bottle guy like
a roof like a reusable water bottle will
you use the refillable water bottle
station at the airport i will yeah
really mm-hmm okay i think that's pretty
clear take care of the impact but here's
the thing if i don't i steal the water
bottles
i've stolen a water bottle every time
everybody steals from the airport
the airport i mean the the first of all
the air yes because it's like you spend
so much your life in an airport that
you're like i need something back from
you you know i understand and also
they're begging you to steal waters
they're out there that no one's around
you a lot of new ones they don't even
have like a checkout person like you
check out you're just supposed to check
out yourself okay i'm like what are you
[__] with not this is disrespectful
oh and it also costs seven dollars i
know if it costs two bucks i would buy
the water but that's you know
so yeah
uh hotel
what about them do you leave uh you've
never been to one
you have that's cool
what do you leave for the cleaning lady
10 bucks 20 bucks okay depends depends
how much i usually don't if i have cash
i'll you know yeah i usually leave 20 of
merch money okay you know good you like
the early check-in you do your early
check-in guy if i you know when i try
and time it so that there's no issues
with
the check-in
um but yeah i'll try and get there as
early as possible you know if i can if i
can check in i'll check in as early as
possible but i like to i like to time it
right around three so there's no no
issue
when they dare say it's not ready to
check in time that's we've had that one
truly despicable you're just like
rolling around rochester or something
yeah yeah i gotta leave here can i leave
my luggage here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i like to avoid that if possible 100 10
bucks that's pretty clear see
he's yeah i use i yeah you know depends
it depends it also depends on
how how long i'm there you know i would
say 10 is a is like if nothing
there's no like yeah are you are you
trash in that room
where was i last sandy in san diego i
think i was just like i left the 20 i
mean i usually leave 20 if it's a full
weekend but if it's like a one night or
here whatever i'll just do whatever
you're going through all those towels
right huh you're going through all the
towels yeah yeah yeah you leave them in
one little area or you do you put them
together a little bit a little bit yeah
yeah dirty yeah yeah [__] gentlemen
over here yeah cool
yeah their lives and the thing is like
typic i do like tipping a lot because
it's just like who gives a [__] i know
it doesn't it does feel nice my life is
barely impacted and like a good tip
makes somebody's [__] day you know so
it's like you know
wait just but if i'm really if i really
[__] a room up oh i might even drop 40.
just because you're like i'm sorry i'm
like i'm really sorry you don't make eye
contact yeah yeah yeah sorry about that
dump in the ceiling oh the smell the
musk
around some of the windows you can't
open yeah
yeah yeah
ladies and gentlemen
brand new debut special that's coming
out june 5th on youtube make sure you
check it out he's one of the absolute
best thanks you're [__] killing it
buddy thank you for having me couldn't
be more powerful i couldn't be more
happy for you thank you same thank you
for coming in and stopping anything you
want the folks out there to know other
than the space yeah just especially
it'll be a live premiere eight o'clock
eastern five o'clock pacific i'll be in
the little chat [__] around you know
i'll have a couple friend you guys are
welcome to come thanks get in the chat
we'll [__] around um but yeah just
follow the youtube you know that's i'm
putting a lot of effort into the youtube
channel he's cooking it's not just the
special i also put two longer videos a
week and every day a very short clip
will be on youtube uh and tick tock
instagram whatever you prefer but yeah
that's the main [__] go that's what i'm
i'm really i really want people to see
this thing and you know what's the name
of your youtube channel it's just my
name stop rush hourkies just just look
me up on youtube and uh yeah that's it
can't wait for the special to come out
thank you boys for having me thank you
very much everybody it really feels like
we did we i literally could do this for
five years this is work
we just argued over pizza he just asked
me the stupidest questions i've ever
heard in my life and i love how you
answer them
but yeah yeah yeah i prefer this more
than any que like any interviews this is
the best in the world i mean i don't
care how you started let's get what are
you dipping your tendons yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you started doing opal i
don't give a [__]
your writing process huh what about the
five alive what are you doing there
gibby what do you got for him uh just
you know check us out youtube patreon
itunes check us out on the road yeah
we're gearing up for a [__] second
leg yeah the second half of it we're
adding like 20 cities or something come
see us there good [__] time yeah gang
we love you we'll see you next week
peace